- Before we say goodbye,
I have a story from the internet
I want to share with y'all.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
More people are keeping goats as pets
and for good reason.
They're great companions, and super fun.
And they'll clear your backyards of weeds,
which is helpful.
Of course, they do come
with a few drawbacks.
The horns can be a problem.
That's Dobby, the goat
who found a loose Cheerio
on the stairs and decided to risk it all.
Sounds like Dobby got into
the stash at home or something.
He really wanted that Cheerio.
Don't worry Dobby!
He was freed.
We have him on the line now
along with his owner,
Isria from their backyard
at North Carolina.
They watch on WCCB Charlotte CW at five.
What's up Isria?
(audience cheering)
- How are you?
- I am so good.
So he seems okay. Dobby seems okay.
- Yeah, he's totally fine.
It was a little bit nerve wracking
when I saw him initially,
but he was fine.
He saw a Cheerio and did
not want it to go to waste
and it took me a minute to figure out
how he got wedged into the stairs,
but he must have just used brute strength
'cuz his horns are curved.
So once he was in, I
could not get him out.
But luckily my luck guy was on the way
and helped me pry up the stairs
and get him out.
- Well I love this.
So Dobby actually has
brothers and sisters, right?
And where are they?
- [Isria] Yes, they are
scattered about right now.
They're all named after
Harry Potter references.
- [Kelly] Yes!
Take that Gwen Stefani.
I thought that yeah, you named Dobby
after a Harry Potter character, yes.
- Oh yeah, it was definitely a reference.
Then I have Lumos and
her daughter Norberta,
we call her Bertie for short.
Extra points if you can
figure out that reference.
And then recently we adopted Padfoot
and Willow from a sanctuary
here in North Carolina.
- That's awesome.
Well, I love you,
and I love all your goats,
and I really love those two
chairs that I wanna come over
and have a drink with
you and just chill in.
Those chairs look real comfortable girl.
The little hanging ones behind you.
Thank you so much, Isria.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience claps)
And that's not all,
our season long partner Pilot pin makers
of Frxion to goats to race
Bull pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those
who live fearlessly
and that includes goats as well, y'all.
So they're giving you a thousand dollars.
(audience cheers)
- Say thank you.
- [Kelly] Thank you so much Isria!
And thank you to all my guests today!
Quin Stefani, Melissa Villasenor,
Dave, Lisa, Audrey, and Myla,
y'all have a great day
and if it's not try and change it.